I grew up in Queens County
I was born in St Joseph's Hospital
September 1st 1944.
my father was in France
in the Army in the accounting Corps
my mother was living with her mother and
father
and for 11 months I lived with my mother
her parents in Far Rockaway and when my
father came home I was 11 months old and
every man approaching the crib my
grandmother or grandfather or mother
would say dada dada dada
so when my father appeared I went dada
dada and he said oh she's so smart it's
my family it's my side of the family
I don't know if I was smart or not smart
and I often tried to think what is my
first memory
because we like to get there in our mind
to see how far we can go back and I
think this is it when a door was opening
I was lying down I was picked up and
somebody said Lamb Chop because I
remember when I was a baby eating all
the time I'm not even a baby boomer I
was one when the war was still on but if
you were healthy in those days you were
fat so I had thighs and a big face and
food all the time because it meant I
guess that you were bringing enough
money in to feed your entire family
so my father comes home and we live with
my grandmother and grandfather for two
and a half years and then we moved to
Laurelton which is also in Queens County
now keep in mind
Far Rockaway where I was born and
queen's count is in Queens County as is
Laurelton but as I grew up I thought New
York City was only Manhattan
you would say you're going into the city
it always meant Manhattan
so here I am growing up in Laurelton
every house looks alike
This Is post-world War II Cape Cod
houses
and I have a brother he's two years and
nine months younger than me and I have
no memory of sibling rivalry early on
I just knew that nobody paid attention
to me they won't pay attention to my
brother either because I had parents
that were Bachelors who got married
they were 11 years apart they had a lot
of interests and their children were
just two interests but not really the
focal point of their attention so I grew
up close to my brother because we hung
out together because I don't know where
my mother and father were
and I remember walking and talking early
and I also remembered my brother Paul
speaking some kind of language he made
up and I was the official translator and
one time he's walking around limping and
my mother turns to me and says what's
wrong with Paul so I asked my brother
and what I'm thinking is English I don't
know and he goes
ma his foot hurts and she would open up
the shoes and she found rolled up socks
inside the shoes
so I grew up close to my brother it's
eventually known as Hansel and Gretel
bonding it happens in the animal kingdom
a sibling provides for you
maternal and paternal affection that you
don't get enough of from your mother and
father it doesn't mean they're mean or
awful they could have five jobs they
could be away traveling they could love
you dearly but they didn't get the love
they needed to express to for their
children so I would say to you I am a
product of total unadulterated benign
neglect maybe my mother was maybe my
father was my father was born in 1907 my
mother was born in 1918 and if you have
a little therapy you begin to understand
you can't teach what you don't know
so I grow up and my grandmother notices
my left eye is crossing not my mother
get the idea where the heck is my mother
I don't know
and I have two eye operations when I'm
five I go to my grandmother's eye doctor
my mother cannot drive she asks a
neighbor to drive me and my mother's in
the back seat I get as far as I remember
not a word of comfort not a word of
saying you'll be okay I just knew I was
on my own early on my mother was
emotionally useless
she yelled all the time everything was
tragic I didn't know if an empty milk
container was the equivalent of
murdering the neighbor
so I have my first set of eye operations
is to cut the muscle and I had wooden
splints on my arms
and I come home and I say to myself I
didn't like those wooden splints because
I I'm told I have to have another eye
aberration so I say to the doctor I'm
five Dr esteman I do not want those
wooden splints you told me not to touch
my eye I will not touch my eye
and he says to me you are the first
child who ever gave me directions
I did not know that was unusual
later on my father would say you always
had a will
and I don't know if Will means you're
stubborn well will means you're born
with a point of view or will means
you're a free spirit because if you
dissect the word free spirit it means
you know your spirit you know what makes
you happy and you work and live through
it by protecting it and your decisions
protect your spirit I don't know and if
you say I don't know throughout your
entire life you open up doors for
understanding because nobody knows
anything we all memorize these answers
we don't have an answer the Mind wants
an answer to the question so we make of
one
so I have eye operations when I'm seven
years old I am sexually molested I could
not tell you this I cannot bring it up
until covet because during covet I
learned to paint
and through painting I saw the person
who molested me
and I understood why I went this way
when I could have gone this way because
I was traumatized
and I understand for those of you out
there who meditate painting is the
highest form of meditation
there's no thinking there's no judgment
you express your emotions through your
acrylics or your oils or your crayons
and there you have your life on canvas
and suddenly I saw this man
we lived in these houses that looked
alike
and across the street from our house
with red shutters
lived a house with green shutters and
Ruth and Arnie Spivak lived there and
Arnie's father molested me in the
basement of that house twice the third
time I told him go away
I couldn't have said this
the way I'm saying it now but I did
mention it in a Solo show that I wrote
In 2017.
I did mention to the director I was
molested but I couldn't give you the
details that I give now or feel the
emotion that I feel now
but I wanted to say to the director it's
in the script but it's not about being
molested it's just one of the things
that happened to me
but through painting I realized
all trauma forms your personality and
Trauma means a wound how are you wounded
and where you are wounded eventually you
will find yourself crippled in
development unless you address it and
I'm 78 and I'm addressing my wounds I'm
in physical therapy because my back gave
out and I'm in mental therapy because
I'm wanting to know
I could die soon how can I develop
myself and open myself to a larger world
if I accept my eye operations if I
accept being molested if I accept my
devotion to my brother who dies which is
when I want to kill myself
that these are parts of my development
and these are parts of what I should
throw into my art or my theater or my
performance pieces because we all suffer
and only the wise see suffering as a
learning experience and we only become
interesting because we suffer
so I grow up in Queens and I knew I was
articulate I knew I was highly energetic
and I knew I was wacky I just wanted to
be with my brother and I kept on asking
my father daddy how do you know when you
know yourself because I had read about
the Oracle at Delphi which says know
thyself
yes what does that mean I want to know
myself
and my father would say go outside and
play ball you're too young to be
thinking like this
it never left me I used to watch Victory
at Sea on TV because I wanted to see
people die because I knew I would die
and that was my first idea that I am
temporary
and I as a temporary person we have to
know who we are and how did I know I was
temporary I was about 10 years old and
Florence rice lives next door and her
sister has multiple sclerosis and every
time I see her she's frailer and paler
her husband first takes her with a cane
then a walker then he's carrying her and
then she dies and I say to my father
what happened to flory's sister
she died and I said Daddy what does that
mean we will never see her again
so I would stare at myself in the mirror
and say one day I won't be able to see
myself and I would cry because what Am I
who am I what do I want I didn't know my
trauma paralyzed my desires and I did
not know my trauma made me feel unworthy
whatever happened to me I accepted so I
I'm I was smart I loved school but at
ninth grade I sort of dipped this way
I didn't care anymore it didn't get me
what I wanted and I couldn't tell you
what I precisely wanted so I graduated
high school
a very overcrowded City school called
Andrew Jackson we were baby boom I
wasn't a baby boomer but baby boomers I
had skipped the eighth grade we had
three sessions
I went to Junior High School 59 the year
it opened up then I went to Andrew
Jackson high school as a sophomore 12 37
to 437 it was too crowded to have a full
schedule for those in attendance
then I went as a junior from 807 to 207
then I went as a senior from 1236 from
807 to 1237 no study no gym no lunch
because it was so overcrowded it was
built for 3 000 students there were five
thousand students in the school
I didn't know I was lost I was lost but
I didn't know I was lost you can't know
you're lost until you're found so I go
to school in Albany the State University
in Albany I just knew I wanted to get
away I didn't know why I wanted to get
away I couldn't tell you the torture I
felt I know zero I don't know anything
but I knew there was no tuition at a
state school in New York and my family
didn't have a lot of money and I was
always aware of that so I went to the
State University at Albany there were
no but the 650 people were my graduating
class I graduated from high school with
1100 people so it's the reverse it's I
went to high school but it was College
it was small it was rural it was so
sweet and adorable and every time there
was a mixer I never went out I never
went to a mixer and I couldn't tell you
why I self-isolated but I can now
I was embarrassed and I was molested
I felt sullied I didn't I didn't know
how to talk to a guy I wasn't interested
in women I just was not trusting of
anyone
I couldn't be close to anyone I didn't
know I was phobic I didn't know I had
self-loathing I knew nothing then I get
money from the University of Illinois I
have a ba in history I get a master's in
teaching social studies at the
University of Illinois in
Urbana-Champaign
I meet a guy his name is Lee Stelzer and
we go out and he's the first guy I have
sex with well I want this is interesting
it's fun I like it and he says something
like this if memory serves I adore you
let's get married and I'm thinking I'm
supposed to get married because I'm on
the cusp of feminism should you be a
virgin shouldn't you be a virgin do you
marry as a virgin how important is sex I
knew nothing
so I said to him I can't marry you I
don't want to do your laundry
and scare the [__] out of me what the
hell one answer is that I never said I
love you I never said I don't love you
oh let's have children I just saw a
marriage as servitude I saw I didn't
know who I was and I can't devote myself
to anybody else who am I
and then in my 20s I had a few other
sexual Liaisons whatever you want to
call it but I never said to myself
I want to get married I want children I
just said I can't do this who am I I
don't even know who I am I have such
self-rage and self-anger so I start out
as a teacher at Herrick Senior High
School in North New Hyde Park I was a
teacher of social studies 10th grade a
fabulous teacher 10 minutes
then I took up smoking because I was
bored I said I got to do something
different so when the teacher's lounge I
would smoke and cough
and I go back to teaching we played the
records Beatles were there I
requisitioned the record player from
Audio Visual and I was a fabulous
teacher when I focused but I didn't know
I had attention deficit hyper disorder I
didn't know I didn't like being indoors
I didn't like seeing the same people
every day and I quit after three years
and then I get a job at random house I'm
a fabulous writer for 10 minutes and I
worked with Tony Morrison I knew her
very well
LW singer was a textbook company they
buy at random house and I'm already
working in random house and I have a
desk three desks away from Tony Morrison
and she says to me one day you never sit
at your desk I said I know I'm Afflicted
I don't know what it is I have to walk
around and she said you don't
concentrate I know I don't concentrate I
don't know how to fix it and she lived
of all places in Laurelton and I lived
in Manhattan she had an apartment she
had two sons and she was asked to look
at the galleys of I always mix them up
between Ebony and Essence one of them
was was a newer one I think it's Essence
ebony is the old one so Essence comes
out Toni Morrison is asked to look at
the galleys and she invites me and a few
other people to look at the galleys with
her I take the train out to Laurelton I
get the heebie-jeebies because I grew up
there and I went oh I was so nervous I
was so anxious not that I'm any
different I was still a nervous and
anxious wreck and then I get fired from
random house I was warned many times
you're never sitting in your seat you
don't finish the assignments but I was
an excellent writer so every time they
gave me anything original to write I was
superb but anything else I didn't want
to do it but I was warned and I get
fired so I decided to move to St Thomas
the Virgin Islands because I didn't know
I had minimum body fat I just knew I was
always cold in the summer and I felt
abandoned and I felt orphaned and I
figured it out
I moved to St Thomas it's always warm
I'll always be happy
I had no idea wherever you go you take
yourself so if I'm malformed
disorganized a nut job well that nut job
goes to a place that has weather from 82
to 92 degrees and all you can do is you
can have sex or you can take drugs or
you can drink that's great on a vacation
not in real life I stayed a year and I
came back and I got a job at Hearst
magazines
as the secretary to the controller the
accounting department so I'm interviewed
by Maria Pirro in the Hurst personnel
office which is today human resources
and she takes a look at me and she goes
what are you doing in business in
accounting he's going to hire you but
you're attractive but this is not for
you you're an actor and my sister Diane
is in an amateur acting troupe and I
think you should call her up and do one
of those plays they do with Saint Gene
the Baptist in the basement
so I get a job with John devolio who's
the controller and it is the worst job I
ever had but I last for two years don't
ask me how or why and I call up Diane
Piero and I go down to Saint John the
Baptist and I get into the place Boone
River Anthology and I loved it I loved
memorizing the words I loved being an
actor I loved whatever it required and
then uh I get fired from the job at her
at Hearst magazines after two years but
I was warned a hundred thousand times my
boss was a sex a sex guy who was always
at Plato's Retreat he was married and he
had a daughter but he had a huge sexual
appetite and I know this and as a
secretary you're supposed to keep your
mouth shut
I didn't do that somebody would say
where's John devolio I'd say he said
Plato's Retreat and he has a bad back I
don't know what he's doing there he's
going to come back crooked and
eventually he says to me you got a big
mouth and I knew you had a big mouth and
I'm gonna fire you
but here's the interesting thing about
my brain while I was the control the one
of the secretaries for the controller
this guy Vince was working for my boss
and his wife was a travel agent this is
before computers and I had this thing
about Marshall Tito I wanted to see
Yugoslavia before it fell apart because
I had a thing for the cult of the
personality Tito
Castro and Anwar Sada but the three
people I worshiped do you see where I'm
out to lunch I'm not in the present
tense and I went to Israel in 1988 but I
didn't go to Egypt because I'm Jewish
and I felt bad I shouldn't go to Egypt
spend my money there but when Sadat was
bumped off I felt awful so I had two
people left Castro and Marshall Tito
well this is in the 70s and Marshall
Tito's alive and he arrests anyone who
disagrees with him so that country's
pretty strong so I say to Vince ask your
wife if she has any tours going to
Yugoslavia
and she comes back he comes back with a
brochure and he gives it to me he says
yes this to her and it's for two and a
half weeks I sign up there's only three
of us on the tour but we We join other
tours while we're in Yugoslavia and the
two other people on the tour was May
Dodge Rogers who grew up in East Hampton
in the libraries named after her family
and the waitress in the diner that she
went all the time as her traveling
companion and I'm a third I love them
both they were nuts I didn't know they
were nuts they were my kind of people
they didn't finish his sentence they
drifted off and we hung out together I
come back and made Dodge Rogers whose
Filthy Rich I did not know this sends me
330 for my 33rd birthday I'm unemployed
I'm taking care of my brother's dog and
I see that 330 dollars and I say to
myself I want to do something if I never
had this money I couldn't do so I said
I'm going to go to acting school I
remembered what Maria pero said you're a
natural actress so I only knew about two
schools the neighborhood Playhouse and
the American Academy of dramatica parts
so I call up the neighborhood Playhouse
and now it's a summer school I didn't
think high school it's high school kids
I just thought it's in the summer at
school and the neighborhood Playhouse
the woman answers the phone and says
we're all booked up for our summer
school
but for you we would open it up you have
a magnificent speaking voice
I started to cry because I want to tell
you something you have to find where
your assets are assets if you have
assets and they're looked at as
liabilities you believe they're your
liability I had a deep voice
I would pick up the phone and people
thought I was my brother Paul
when I was teaching I was very good
friends with Janice Goldberg her mother
says to me your voice is like a man's is
there any way you can raise it
and I took whatever anyone said to me as
to my heart and I thought it was my
fault there's something wrong with me
that I didn't fit in and I want to tell
you something the biggest gift you can
give yourself is to honor that you don't
fit in
so the neighborhood Playhouse says we
will open it up for you come down with a
monologue I didn't know what you was
talking about a monologue and I said how
much is it she said 350 so I saw that as
a sign from God I had 330 dollars we're
a bad fit so I call up the American
Academy of dramatic arts they had
openings it was 330 dollars so I go to
acting school at the American Academy of
dramatic arts it was the summer of I'm
going to make it up when I'm close 77
1977. I was the oldest person by 20
years everybody was in high school
however if the acting teacher said to me
lie down on the floor and pretend you're
the color red I said okay I'll do that I
had no argument I didn't say we didn't
do that in high school we didn't do that
in my drama class I had no template
whatsoever at the end of the six weeks
Dennis Moore who was my acting teacher
said you are a natural actress but now
would be actor you are a natural actor
why don't you think of going to school
at the American Academy but go at night
but you're coming in with a lot of stuff
and I was a sponge because I had no
Direction ever from anyone and I always
took what someone else saw me as as what
I was because I was empty I didn't know
who I was
nor did I get direction ever from my
mother and father even to rebel against
so I go to the American Academy of
dramatic arts at night I loved every
moment four nights a week I loved every
moment
I graduate
I auditioned for one role
I tried
and it comes out like a death bell
I'm scared to death I call up my cousin
Alvin who's a doctor and he says to me
I'll give you beta blockers
what are they they slow down your
heartbeat no I will just never audition
again so I become a waitress in
zlatnick's daughter that is a restaurant
on the bottom of the city core building
which is the building and the Horizon
that has a slanty roof it was okarant
technologically advanced when it opened
up in the 70s because it had a tuned
Mass damper on the roof that controlled
the wind velocity around the edifice to
adjust to anything that could happen to
the foundation
and I'm a waitress and zlatanic's
daughter and they always think I'm slot
Nick's daughter no she was someone in
Canada and we had a manager and it was
like a diner and I had regulars because
I would sit down with everybody and talk
to them of course my manager hit the
ceiling he says what's the matter with
you you're a waitress you should be
walking around I said well I just love
everybody I want to talk to them and I
would give away free brownies free
blondies because we had a huge dessert
bar and two guys would come in all the
time and one of them finally says to me
I think you should become a tour guide
we work at grayline you're such a
natural Storyteller you were born here
and you have such an interesting point
of view
well I listened to that and they and I
said how do you become a tour guide he
said you got to go down to 80 Lafayette
Street and take a test so I went down to
80 Lafayette Street at that time it was
the Department of Consumer Affairs I
took a test how to become a tour guide
it was multiple choice it was fill in
there were no essays because the guy who
answered it was from Pakistan he
couldn't even understand English so it
was a b a c true false too false and you
pass or you fail while I was a waitress
at zlotnik's daughter Meryl Streep came
in because Meryl Streep was appearing in
I want to say social security it was
right next door at a little theater
night right next to us the city Corps
building in Saint it's a church a little
theater and she had glasses on that were
missing an ear and I said to her you
need to get a safety pin and put the ear
in she says well I'll get around to it
she wore overalls and later on she
became world famous so I take the test I
go to grayline I look for those two guys
one's name was Jim the other was George
and they said ask Max he's the
dispatcher tell him you're here as a
student guide so I was a student guide I
sat in the back of the bus I had passed
the test it was a very fair test I got
some questions wrong but it was an
overview of if you're in New York what
things should you see and some kind of
understanding of the city itself and
then he Max said to me when you feel
you're ready
you come and tell me and I will give you
a tour
so I worked I don't know how many times
maybe 10 times in the back of the bus
I'm making that up and you make it up
you think oh I'm ready because it's
really Hands-On what are you ready for
anyway nothing who knows what's gonna
happen so I get the tour and Max says
well we have a new driver with you and I
say to him
you're crazy I need an old driver I know
he says it's not Union rules so I have a
new driver from New Jersey a bus that we
subcontracted and me I don't know what
I'm doing and I'm nervous and you know
when you're nervous you sabotage
yourself and it's the Gay Day Parade so
the only route I know is occupied by
people who are in the parade so I stayed
in the driver right by Washington Square
make a left he said I can't make a lift
it's not what it's not wide enough for
my the back of my bus and we couldn't
back up I mean years later I got into
things and I would run out and back up
the traffic but then I was paralyzed I
didn't know what I was doing I said you
can do it you can do it think positive
so he turns and he hits the car so the
first day out I'm in a bus accident
and the police come everybody comes and
I think they'll never hire me again but
they did and they called me demolition
Debbie so I worked at great line for x
amount of years as a freelancer I liked
it I liked it a lot but you know what I
liked the microphone
giving you my point of view and I had
information it wasn't I wasn't a sham I
was quite good but I was funny I am
funny and I was interesting and I like
strangers
it's intimacy that kills me I like the
fluidity of new people in front of me
continuously and I got to be known and I
worked a lot I never worked a lot
because people annoy me I worked maybe
four months a year and I lived very
modestly and I was in The Daily News
centerfold
I there was a little article about me in
New York Magazine
um I was interviewed on TV a lot because
I'm a little off the wall see here's an
example
my Insanity in real life works as a tour
guide because people want to be
entertained while they're learning they
want to be with someone who's a little
off the wall a little unusual who brings
in things from the outside world and
makes a sort of a conclusion but in real
life if you're talking to someone like
that you can drive them crazy but now I
don't apologize anymore
and I have to say to you stay with it
you have to find out who you are it's
the Wilderness you are the Wilderness
but if you give up you might as well
kill yourself emotionally spiritually
while you're standing vertical and
everything is courage everything is the
ability to see the unknown as a gift not
to scare you to death which it has done
in the past and you have to own your
Frailty you have to own your
vulnerability you have to own what what
you missed out
and give it to yourself so in the end
which is our beginning which is our
rebirth we become our own mother father
sister brother lover
what are the advantages of living in New
York City
first of all if you lift your all your
life you don't even know what's unusual
that's the unusual thing about it you
have to travel to see that where you
live is a little bubble it doesn't exist
anywhere else and then once you travel
and you see that it doesn't exist
anywhere where else and you come back
and you cherish it but you don't cherish
it for the commodity that people think
it is you cherish it not in a money
sense and not in what you can buy in the
air that you breathe because what's in
the air you breathe the variety of Life
the choices that we all make the what we
live with our own little stories they're
all in the corner and the world every
ethnic group is here all the languages
are on the corner you feel insignificant
because let me tell you you are
insignificant you're respect and when
you live here this spec is apparent
because you're going to disappear not
only do you respect it's a double whammy
you're not going to be here forever
you're temporary so why do you think
you're so important why are you a
solipsist why are you the center of the
universe you are not and once you
discover the universe is around you you
can travel
going to the corner and talking to
different people your eyes open up what
are the options here there are immense
and what are people walking with they're
walking with Blood Sweat and Tears and
tragedy and how do you know that you got
to talk to them and how do you talk to
them you find the question that opens
them up because we all want to be heard
we all have a story we want to be
excited we want exertion we want energy
and we want exercise and when we don't
get those we become depressed and some
of us don't know that we don't have them
and we walk around depressed because
suddenly they laugh
and they say you know I haven't left and
so on and one of the gifts that I have
and I don't know where it came from I
always had a sense of humor even at my
brother's funeral
I said to my father now I'm going to
inherit whatever money you have that's
the advantage of having Paul die so what
in the talk is that well I'm trying to
find something not that you have any
money Daddy but you don't have another
Heir I'm the only issue well what kind
of talk is that oh I don't know I'm just
trying to constantly myself what's the
word did I want to console myself
because some things are unconsolable and
you make up how you console yourself the
loss of a brother you will never get
over the loss of a child you will never
get over and the people who you love
bring out things in you that other
people don't so what is your grief your
grief your grief is the absence of their
Corporal presence because their presence
brings out something in you and if you
can't find it in another person it is an
ongoing absence and you live with it and
that's why I love the color spectrum
because the colors run from Blue True
Blue Green With Envy bred with rage
orange for conciliation yellow for
Sunshine you put it together and why am
I wearing this
it's tone on tone why am I wearing this
because I knew I was going to be in the
camera and I know I speak in a very damn
very dense and I'm very intellectual and
I can be thick and I can be thought
provoking and I just wanted to be ready
for this calmer in my attire because I
didn't want to conflict with my verbiage
and what I have to say to you also is
you never know parts of yourself unless
you try it and don't underestimate how
brilliant you are and who you are you do
underestimate it because it's fear and
fear is going to come and strangle you
in the neck and you'll be paralyzed
petrified like a tree so what you have
to pretend is you have to act like
you're confident
like you can do anything act like you
know what you're doing because nobody
knows what they're doing and life is a
series of disappointments and that's the
truth because we have expectations that
we make up we should go in it with no
expectation the only time you should
applaud yourself is when you try
something new and you live through it
and you didn't embarrass yourself to the
degree and I want to tell you how I
embarrass myself but you get over it I
have irritable bowel syndrome and
sometimes I'll eat something and I'll
make in my pants in the in public
and I have to go to a strange bathroom
and say excuse me I had an accident
and you know something you live you live
you live you live through everything
until you can't live through everything
what do you wish you knew
what do you wish you understood in your
20s and 30s and 40s that you understand
now it's the irony of it you only
understand through aging that most
things don't matter
but when you're young you say oh my God
my hair I can't make the house my hair's
sticking up and I got the pimple over
here and then he said and then she said
and I didn't know what to say and I want
to shoot myself none of this matters but
I think you have to go through it to
look back look as a Kierkegaard says the
only life worth living is you're looking
backwards but we're going forward
and I also like schopenhauer nobody
likes him they say he's a depressive but
I don't think he's a depressive I think
he's realistic the only side that these
are these are my words of schopenhauer
the only sign there is a God out there
the only Divine quality we have is our
sense of humor
then when you laugh you think oh
there's something larger than me because
I didn't know I was going to laugh and I
didn't know I was going to make someone
else laugh and if you can laugh
and cry you had a good day I think you
should laugh and cry every day because
life's filled with emotions what's your
personality your personality is
emotionally based
so depressed people are sitting on their
emotions they didn't have an Avenue for
expression get an exercise take up
running take up a musical instrument
scream and yell make a fool of yourself
don't sit on anything you'll get an
ulcer
I don't know if you'll get it also but
you'll get neurodermatitis you'll start
me scratching and if you have someone
that you disagree with learn the skills
that don't shut down the communication
where you can communicate have your
point but the person doesn't leave the
room or tell you to drop dead
that's a skill and that's a gift to give
yourself when you can express yourself
without annihilating the person who's
listening if you had your life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently oh I I don't know if I don't
know I don't like the word regret
because how can you know what you don't
know because you don't even know you
don't know it you make lousy decisions
I wish I knew early on
how much sex is a part of relationships
with men or women I I was so scared of
it because I was molested I I was so
uncomfortable with it I didn't look I
looked down I looked up I had sex but
it's not like I had sex I wasn't in my
body I I wish I I caught my trauma
earlier I wish I caught my trauma oh
somebody said go into therapy because
this this and this is crippling you I
didn't have the courage or the Insight
or the foresight or I don't know to see
it until Colvin and then I took a
painting and painting released me but
I'm closing in on death it's the irony
of it I'm closing in on my exit and I'm
wanting to make an entrance because I'm
now entering as my real person but I
don't think you can be real unless you
fall on your face you I don't think
anyone's born whole those very lucky
people know exactly what they want to do
early on but are they lucky
I mean sometimes you can say confusion
can make you a more interesting person
trying things out that don't work out
can make you more interesting a patina
of interest you come over to someone you
say oh they have so much to say this a
lot of things didn't work out for them
when everything works out for you you
don't get a story what is the story
based on disappointment and expectations
but you live through it and every story
builds your character and I remember
when I was growing up my mother and
father would say put your pinky put your
finger down I was harmless but I was
taught like this harmless and I wish I
knew I was good looking
I didn't know that I wish I knew that my
because my father never said you're so
beautiful you know I had very good
looking mother and father a good looking
brother he just was character driven
character who are you no one ever told
you you're beautiful no recently they
have you know what the first time when
someone told me I was beautiful I was on
a tour and someone said to me a guy I
Can't Take My Eyes Off You I said why
it was an enigma in me I was invisible
to myself I didn't see it now I see it I
have never looked better here's the
conundrum of Aging when you age with
reality and authenticity you never
looked better
simultaneously you've never looked older
so it goes together I can't figure it I
don't have anything done with me
but here's my beautiful thank you you're
beautiful your energy I'm going to take
my head off okay
um I I want to say this to everyone and
I want to say to myself a little girl on
this side of me because what's happening
to all of us we walk around with the
child that we how does it we've also I'm
still in here that same sensitive
confused the little child is there and
the adult has to become the parent to
the child and if the adult is nervous
that's me you get two nervous people
living in one body and you become
neurotic and I was early on very
talented but scared of everything and if
you're frightened you're crippled and
somehow you have to work that through
and I I don't have an easy suggestion
because
I'm 78
and I'm willing to go with the what life
has to offer now but I could die at 80.
we all could die so let me rephrase that
my back is bad and I don't know if
that's aging or I'm giving up things
that I carry that I shouldn't have
carried before I don't feel anything in
my feet well maybe I'm not supposed to
feel so much I don't know I like
everything is a metaphor
we all have regrets
period but I want to use a better word
than regret we all needed adaptation
earlier on we just didn't adapt we
didn't know it and I remember
um oh what's her name she's a black
American the Caged Bird Sings Maya
Angelou she said and this is genius if
you know better you do better
I wish I knew better earlier
I think just earlier I would have had
more fun I'm having a lot of fun now
because I recognize all my lovely
qualities but I didn't recognize them I
just thought I was a failure because
I'll tell you what I did I saw this is
the way you go through life I didn't
know I was creative creative people or
artists are this they're over here and
the people I knew I'm not saying they
weren't artists they suppressed their
art they didn't touch it they went this
way I wanted to go that way I was so
awkward with men I was so awkward with
the idea that you have to get married
and have children I was so young do you
have kids no and I I never wanted kids
but now I could be a good mother yeah
because I get it I know what love is
you'd be a great mother yes I know what
love is I I really can be I'm now
appearing to myself so I I was afraid of
everything but I look cocky you know you
overcompensate you look arrogant and
cocky but you don't know what you're
doing the other thing I want to tell you
also
learn to grieve
that's what I'm doing now I'm grieving
because of the things I didn't do
earlier the things I didn't learn sooner
allow yourself to grieve you'll go
through it and you'll become stronger
and better
look at yourself in the mirror and say
you're making it through you know life
is difficult a lot of people drink
themselves into Oblivion take drugs
because they don't want to be here I'm a
Daydreamer and my therapist says own
that that's who you are you're
daydreaming saved you from doing
anything wrong you're just a day dreamed
that reality was better but it's a gift
you give yourself if you can learn to
live with reality you've had loves in
your life
I had this is a wonderful question for
what you mean the opposite I don't think
I'm gay I didn't get I didn't look at
women and say oh a vagina is really what
I want I once had a little tree but a
triage with a man and a woman neither
one appealed to me I mean because he I
didn't like him and like her so I I
would say to you I'm perfectly straight
but picky I'm a saber sexual whatever
that thing is I love brilliant people I
love people who make me laugh and I just
I just I can't help I mean I can't help
it I never looked at a woman with lust
I've looked at a few men but not a lot
of men so it's not like oh that's crazy
right across the board okay when I was
uh you never just you never had anybody
that just did it for you because I
didn't know who I was you know you can I
can have someone now doing it for me
because I know what I want but you
didn't I didn't even know it then so I
would say my earliest experience that
was was Lee in graduate school because
my first sexual experience and he
proposes to me and I didn't this is the
thought that Shook Me Up well I don't
know if I want to get married but I
thought I wanted to but you know you
think you want something until someone
asks you and then when your answer
shocks you that means you really don't
want it because this is the other thing
I want to tell you this is your belly
brain this is your cerebral brain this
is the brain that curses you out centers
you and fear it makes you frightened
your belly brain your intestines your
gut that's your truth
probably a belly breed so when Lee said
to me let's get married and I said oh I
don't want to do your laundry
belly brain and I listen to it but
here's get gets worse six weeks later I
changed my mind because everybody I knew
was getting married so I call him up
it's either six or eight weeks later and
he found another
and I said to myself
I was right
how can you find safe this is the love
of your life what the hell that means
how could you find somebody else in
eight six or eight weeks so I know then
I started finding uh people who were not
white very attractive Chinese people
African-Americans Indians when I went to
graduate school I was so popular this is
before this then I meet Lee but I was so
popular with men I was shocked why
because I went from high school where I
was invisible in in college you didn't
know I love yourself and you couldn't
accept it yes I I think we go back to
that's a big problem for a lot of people
a big problem is lack of worth lack of
self-love and thinking you deserve
certain things you deserve them because
you're a lovely human being and I think
once we cross that road of understanding
if we're not best friends with ourselves
we're doomed every day you wake up you
have two choices you can be your own
best friend or Your Own Worst Enemy it's
a choice every single day
you have to sleep eight hours a day you
have to eat correctly because you've got
to honor the vessel this is the external
you are inside your vessel you've got to
honor this vessel with correct
nourishment but I didn't know that
either I had a self-loathing I didn't
have self-care
you cannot be around people who
denigrate you who criticize you who make
you wrong you cannot tolerate them
because the world out there is out to
eviscerate you
and you have to be brave and bravery
comes from not being afraid of being
alone
not being afraid of the dark and not
being afraid of the unknown and when you
are brave and you are courageous
you can get a hold of the very kernel of
who you are and embrace it and run with
it and it's so much more exciting
absolutely life is so much more exciting
when you know who you are my dad used to
say when I was a kid you don't drink you
don't smoke you don't chase girls you
don't what you don't what do you do
I think I have a gambling problem but
not not a casino like I can go to Vegas
and walk through a casino and think it's
boring
but my gamble is with with my career
with work with things like that like
this this project is is tremendously
risky now but not when I'm interviewing
someone like you but some of the other
people I've interviewed are well you
could get something some would go nuts
in front of you all kinds of problems
yes and like or go after you or hit the
camera or or have a breakdown in front
of you and you don't know what to do
that blend of risk and my creativity my
art
is just addictive to me but but I'll
tell you it's something true truthfully
you can walk out of the house whatever
your House's apartment tent and get hit
with a brick or get run over or get a
misfire you know if somebody shoots at
him but they hit you by mistake as soon
as you leave your confines of what your
safety zone is um we don't I don't even
know what a safety zone is but your
safety zone you're subject to risk
and risk is scary and I want to live
with risk I was frightened of it and I I
don't want to be friend of anything I
run towards it yeah in a way you want to
run towards it not being stupid not
stupid yes but you want you don't want
to jump in the pool when there's no
border but shallow I'll paddle a dog
paddle but uh I I want to believe this
is maybe a little cocky cocky stupid
meaning like 78 that I could still find
love yep you can and it looks it could
be I could still find love I can still
find work that's that has an income for
me that touches my essence of humor and
inspiration and being older I have a lot
to offer being older and play with words
and go out there and wear silly clothing
and just be there and be present and I
just want to love life and I I'm only
doing it now that I'm in bad shape but
I'm only using my back as a metaphor
that maybe I'm releasing things that I
shouldn't have been holding on to so
long so I I I'm I welcome any queries
about my philosophy of life my
philosophy of life would be this say yes
to most things say yes unless your
life's endangered or it's unethical
and I would also have
a code I'm very ethical I hate this
expression ethical I'm I like to do
what's right if I know what right is I
like to fall asleep without worrying
about the phone ringing in the middle of
the night I like to tell the truth if I
know what the truth is and I want to
have a day where who I am matches my
behavior I want to have a day where
peace of mind because of the correct
decision invades my property I want to
have a day this is the biggest thing I
learned in therapy when I was in first
in therapy I can say when someone asks
me a question I don't know can I get
back to you
or that may not work for me may I get
back to you or no I don't want to do
that thank you you don't know boundaries
if you're a people pleaser you're
screwed you have to know your boundaries
and then once you've establish your
boundaries watch Who falls away the
people who fall away I'm not your
friends anyway your friends are really
happy for you when you are successful
with your life they show up and applaud
your friends are there when you have a
car crash you call them when you win the
lottery you call them who do you call
when you're at either end of your
emotional spectrum extreme extreme
ecstasy or extreme despair those are
your friends everyone else is in between
and you have basically 15 people in your
life that you can say is your circle but
you have one good friend if you're lucky
and if you don't can't find anybody it's
got to be you you're your default best
friend you wake up every day and say I'm
going to eat right sleep right do right
have a good day and not worry about
things I can't control and I'm a natural
Warrior I think the Russians are coming
to get me any minute and I have to
heighten a root bait basement I gotta
get over my bad tape my bad tape is
catastrophic
catastrophizing everything and that
comes from trauma that is a trauma
response if something doesn't go the way
you thought it would be it's the end of
you you'll be in the Salvation Army
you'll be eating cat food and that is a
trauma response you have to look at
evidence what is the truth what is your
reality and you also have to believe you
have something precious to offer because
in essence you are precious cargo at the
very least to you and if you don't honor
that you will put yourself In Harm's Way
and you will destroy who you are and
we're here to Blossom and to Blossom in
place and we're here to take courage and
put it inside of us and that's our
bandwidth
and you live with your bandwidth and
that's courage
Jane what would you say one message you
would give to the audience watching
everyone this is
an ageless message
if someone asks you to do something go
somewhere and your life's not in danger
and it's not unethical and you can read
about your behavior in tomorrow's paper
which is now on the internet you say yes
because you may get a story you may find
out about yourself you may it's the
unknown you got to say yes if you say no
which I did so much in my life you don't
get a story it's a flat line you know
exactly what it looks like you're safe
in your cocoon so say yes
you're amazing